casimir aa attention matelots bonjour la
roja ya du vent dans les voiles
pour jouer il vire attention au sailhenc
pas de femmes à bord compris oui oui
qu'en penses tu il m'inquiète vraiment
vous êtes là vous c'est vous avez vu
arriver quasiment julie et moi on est
très inquiet écoutez rester avec nous et
regarder le un moment pas réagir et à
l'asie c'est nous les gars les cols
bleus on n'a jamais prendre au dieu
partout du chili jusqu'en chine du les
plus petits jusqu'aux plus grands de
moussaillons commandant comment de quoi
être inquiet jamais je n'ai vu dans un
état pareil
il a l'air complètement la boule vous
devrez peut-être appeler le médecin
annexé sûrement pas il sera capable de
l'envoyer dans un asile de fous non il
faut mieux les parler calmement
alors tu t'inquiètes pas tu restes là et
moi j'y vais sois prudent parce qu'il a
vraiment peur on ne t'en fais pas quoi
qu'il arrive
casimir ne veut pas devenir meilleur
casimir qu'est ce que ce un bien c'est
moi françois
ah oui bonjour matelots casimir
j'aimerais te parler rappelez-moi
quartier-maître casimir
bon ben si tu veux quartier-maître
casimir que se passe-t-il on dirait que
tu deviens fou moi mais pas du tout je
me prépare à embarquer sur un grand
navire tu veux entrer dans la marine
ouais et alors mais comment ça se fait
tu as rencontré des marins qui te
proposait de temps marqué sur leur avis
non mais j'ai vu une affiche qui avait
posé le capitaine d'un grand bateau et
ils recherchent pour partir avant leur
tour du monde
un quartier maître expérimenté est alors
alors alors je m' expérimente nos feux
que du mur
ce banc faisant semblant de tirer sur un
câble en chantant des vieilles chansons
de marins et en poussant quelques jurons
que deviendra un quartier maître
expérimenté c'est vrai tu crois dans le
vide maintien frémir est-ce que tu
connais simplement les principaux mot
qu'emploient les marins mais ouais bien
sûr rien à redire moussaillons à
l'abordage pas de quartier
mon pauvre casimir tu as lu beaucoup
trop de livres de corsair non ce ne sont
pas ces mots là dont je te parle
ah bon lesquels alors c'est bien la
poupe la proue 1 l'écoutille la poule b
les broutilles non écoute attend attend
les enfants vont nous aider les enfants
venez avec moi et julie tu prends un
bateau et d'une houle apporte d'accord
d'accord
à suivre dans les replis dans l'herbe
tu peux le garder ça se complique alors
voilà ce qu'on va faire
isabelle bon les enfants vous allez
aider casimir apprendre les principaux
mots du langage des marraines êtes
d'accord
et chez vous vous allez nous aider aussi
alors comment que veut dire la proue
celle d'isabelle c'est l'avant du bateau
lors dé l'arrière et l'arrière c'est la
poupe alors casimir je te répète l'avant
du bateau c'est la proue et la poupe et
l'arrière c'est la route à la poupe et
la coupe c'est enregistré la poule
d'arthur être l'asie ni d'ordre ou est
là quand on est sur son bateau et qu'on
regarde l'avant quel est le terme qu'on
emploie pour dire droite dont il souffre
river pascal et gauche à bord bâbord de
ses parfums temps avant vous êtes des
marins expérimentés
c'est pas comme casimir d'abord par
coups bas bataille à gaza mais à bâbord
tribord bagouet bâbord tribord ça y est
bonne on verra ça tout à l'heure à tort
avant qu'est ce que c'est qu'une
écoutille
c'est pourquoi ces hommes diedrick
ficelles déjà on n'est pas des ficelles
doivent jamais des fils la wii ne sais
pas cela non sans une écoute et sonné
chez vous je vais vous montrer y en a
pas d'écouter sur ce seul à lire mais
c'est une ouverture dans le pont pour
pénétrer à l'intérieur du navire mais
qu'est ce que c'est que la coupe est
donc pas une porte alors la coupe et
élimine la coupe et la coupe et oya la
coupe est un oui c'est qu'ils assurent
les canadiens n'ont alors isabelle
pascal je crois qu'il a déjà dû réponse
là bas j'ai soufflé mois il semble
entendre la réponse est bien là qui sait
y en a pas non plus sur ce navire et
c'est une ouverture qu'il y aurait sur
le côté là briller pour fixer une
échelle ou un escalier pour monter à
bord et les barques et rouge et damien d
qu'est ce que j'ai dit pascal entre la
coupe et à william michel paris si
effectivement il mordu à l'échelle elle
sera ici comme ça il y aura une
ouverture ici et on posera les chaînes
saada corps voilà tu as bien compris
casimir oui mais bien sûr y'a pas de
problème oui vous que je ne suis pas
persuadé du voit une question un peu
plus difficile que veut dire fils et 20
noeuds il diedrick dire que ça te dit
quelque chose non pascal fils et 20
noeuds fils evan eux ça veut dire faire
20 milles marins dans leurs poulains et
qu'est-ce que zack hamil marin
casimir linda manz essayer une distance
à distance de combien on doit donc de
combien quand et combien c'est une
grande distance de la course casimir ami
marc faye 1852 m on a donc la fille les
vingt neuf fr 20 milles marins à l'heure
où l'art 1852 x 20 je pensais il dit mme
kazemi le roulis et le tangage
samedi quelque chose le roulis et le
tangage
oui ça te dit quelque chose il va
montrer sa médaille comme toi qui vas
montérégiens supposons que nous soyons à
bord d'un bateau comme ça oui
qu'est ce que c'est que le roulis ça
roule ça roule mais bien moi je te le
dis le roulis c'est le mouvement du
bateau de tribord à d'abord sous l'effet
des vagues qui viennent de côté alors
comme ça de l'art arabe l'avant du
bateau et la roue à l'avant alors
attention bâbord tribord
c'est le roulier devoir y passer d'or
bayrou lima lors c'est le roulis tangage
c'est dans l'autre sens c'est à dire de
l'avant vers l'arrière
sous l'effet du vent de face la ou de
dos voilà c'est le tangage tangage
engage engage le rôle y compris qassimi
hollywoodien on lit à du tangage quand
tu regardes tu engages temps avant hier
à tribord le roulis d'abord en fois
rigolo mais ton silence de la mère de
samy à disparaître
françois c'est fini je n'arrive t le
casimir je m'engage plus dans la marine
et pourquoi non parce qu'avec ton temps
gaz pour roulis j'ai déjà un de ces
mâles de mer aux thèses email